Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, here's someone calling
in with some suspicions about what might have
caused all of those technical problems during
the Ron DeSantis Twitter Spaces launch.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. This is Courtney from
Cleveland. I was just calling because I think
I know why Ron DeSantis is having all of these
technical difficulties. He must have gotten the
COVID vaccine. And so now that he is magnetized,
none of this tech works. Right. It's sort of like
a be kind rewind situation for anyone who saw
that movie. But anyways, I wanted to let you know
that your Ron DeSantis is spot on listening to it.
You do a lot of impressions, but you do a really
good meatball. So keep up the good work and and I
can't wait to hear the next show.
Speaker 1: I actually think that my
Ron DeSantis impression is bad. I don't I think
what I thought what was funny about it was that
it's bad. What I do is I basically try to move
the discussion back to my throat. I move to and I
just try to sound whiny. Florida's where Woke goes
to die. We're not going to allow these people to
come here and tell us that adverbs and pronouns
and proper nouns are going to be. We're just
not going to do it. And that's why me. That's
why I launched on Twitter. SpaceX is alongside
Elon Musk because he's for free speech and I'm
banning books. And so it's just the natural.
I don't think it's a good impression. I thought
what was funny was how bad it was, but at least
at least one person likes it. All right, folks,
this is serious. On the bonus show today. Over
the weekend, producer Pat ran a half marathon.
Producer Pat collapsed at the finish line,
not fed it metaphorically. Usually when Trump
collapsed, people say, Oh, you don't literally
mean that. Pat collapsed at the at the on the
bonus show. Pat collapsed at the finish line.
Heat stroke. Blacked out. Next thing he remembers
is he woke up in an ice bath and subsequently at
the hospital. This happened to CNN's John Berman
when he ran a full marathon a little while ago.
Producer Pat has been medically cleared to be
back on the bonus show. He will join us on the
bonus show and we will talk about it. He says
there's funny thing, he said it was serious
for a little bit, but that some funny things
also happened. So we're going to discuss that
on the bonus show and more. Sign up at join
Pacman dot com folks. Don't miss the bonus.
Speaker 2: O the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: And if you miss the Memorial Day
discount code email info at David
Packman dot com asking for it. We
will get you that code. Don't miss
today's bonus show quotes, please.